I want Eleanor to win but I think God of
War is going to win the best narrative
ghost too I'm glad I didn't go pee
God of War Ragnarok yeah come on guys
you had to see that coming bro you had
to have seen that coming nobody
understood the reason I have a job on
YouTube is because no one understands
the narrative about the ring like come
on all right I'm going pee I'll be right
back the best art Direction Eldon Ray
Eldon round of War Ragnarok the art
direction is unmatched with Elven Rings
it's so good
and the game award goes if this goes to
scorn yeah let's go
[Applause]
surprised they didn't make that a bigger
deal art direction is so important I
feel like art direction is a huge deal
and they just kind of ran it like
rambled it off and the game award for
games for Empire yeah I got nothing on
these unfortunately
see why did that have a bigger reveal
than art Direction
[Applause]
it's time for another world premiere
bloodborne2 let's go give it to me give
me bloodborne 2 now
Horizon God damn it
damn it boring ass game hi bro sorry
games is boring bro is this DLC
what
is this the third game
I didn't even hear what that guy said
sifu
I mean I don't know I didn't play it I
feel like they said Seafood wrong there
like they really mispronounced sifu to
anyone in chattan who has not played
Seafood go play it immediately everyone
first let's head to Japan for a special
announcement uh uh go ahead and give it
to me right now baby you said Japan
excuse me
mankind Empire
is this armored Core maybe producer or
blue protocol
what the [ __ ] is blue protocol
I oh my God I thought that was father
gascoigne for a second that freaked me
out
that looked pretty cool I would probably
play that oh God
yes I like the energy as you can see I'm
now dude I have cringed so much on this
in game awards bro say hi it's starting
to affect me what do you want to play do
you have a certain game or uh oh dead
rings
I didn't imagine you being a soulsborne
player what
do you have a favorite boss in Elder
ring
uh radon
millennia
yeah he's the guy who's gonna say the
[ __ ]
they're still thinking about it she's
pretty tough in the game uh well now
that I know you're such a big game fan
have you ever thought about kind of
appearing in your own game or having an
animal game oh yeah yeah no I'm not
talking about a [ __ ] animal game
come on do that or not but uh give me a
trailer
Crossing you are not doing this right
now that one's taken the Nintendo
lawyers might have some issues with that
but anyways animal it's great to have
you here at the game awards should we
maybe give out an award now what do you
think about that oh yeah music music
okay animal has spoken let's check out
the nominees oh my God I'm gonna Elden
ring should win this by the way
no yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
no it's the same music as 2018 no
goes to
God of War Ragnarok
hitting me
no way
it's the same there's like 50 unique
tracks in Elden ring and God of War has
the same music from 2018 pretty much uh
I was moved that's weird bro stay mad
yeah
I'm also I'm mad from the control of
saying Elden ring and then talking about
Animal Crossing
I don't care about this
you're telling me this doesn't win
this doesn't win
[Music]
because you're delusional
you're telling me this doesn't win
[Music]
listen to this
I thought I just don't care about the
game on the screen
look at this
this
look at how many I'm finding this right
here
this is one of the most beautiful
soundtracks I've ever heard
I'm literally making the trailer on the
screen better
[Music]
listen listen this drop right here
I don't remember a single uh track from
God of War that wasn't from 2018.
Oh Hey listen how about this right here
huh
gave me food chills dude
[Music]
what am I looking at
it's music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh my God I could care for less about
crash
oh my god oh
[Music]
all right I got I gotta listen what
they're saying I don't know what they're
doing for what Innovation and
accessibility it's a single player and
multiplayer experience so we want to
draw in people who weren't necessarily
Gamers I might be able to get up there
if you help
I'm playing that that looks good
what is that Lords of the Fallen huh
okay yeah I'll play that play like hold
on we didn't we didn't get the full
scope there hold on guys
listen to this [ __ ]
right here
[Music]
and the game award goes to elves and
ring congratulations best RPG boys let's
go baby here are the nominees for
Players whose voice are 100 thanks for
making those category you guys are very
busy thank you Angel two days appreciate
it man but yeah I I think it is a
literal crime that Elden Rings music
with all of that Unique Style so many
different tracks lost to God of War I
think is ridiculous if God of War Wins
Game of the Year it'll make sense to me
if eldering Wins Game of the Year it'll
make sense to me but I thought for sure
I was a hundred percent certain that
Elden ring would it would win musical
score just for how unique it is how many
different tracks there are that is
ridiculous that God of War Ragnarok won
that that's [ __ ] stupid I will say
that I will not say the same if God of
War Wins Game of the Year I won't but
musical score definitely been watching
some twitch streamers come for the
awards and they've been calling God of
War cut scene the game it literally is
you just watch it basically and Elder
Rings should win for best game Direction
goes to
join myself let's go baby big win I love
you
what are you premiering what do you got
for me
how many times that's a [ __ ] plane
there are no planes an Elven ringman
come on oh [ __ ]
dude that's a big addition wow
Phantom Liberty what's up get yourself
ahead
okay
that's big that's I'll play that that
looks great if it works share with you
another Global game announcement please
this comes from one of the most
decorated developers in the world please
who consistently pushes this medium
forward for each of its releases you are
literally describing Elden ring multiple
times for Game of the Year here at this
very show and I am beyond please please
please please please those in the game
awards as the place this is it this
Global this is [ __ ] it it's literally
it it has to be
please
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] yes [ __ ] yes armored Core
Maybe
[Applause]
armored Core
[Music]
whoa
this is still a huge announcement guys
foreign
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
that looks really cool
[Music]
feed the fire
whoa
get me every time with your [ __ ]
environmental storytelling let the last
Cinders burn
huh
yep armor Core 100 percent
whoa this looks really really cool
[Music]
yo
[Music]
[Music]
it's kind of like they're going yeah
still a dark Style
[Music]
I was expecting armored Core but I did
not expect it to be like this this looks
awesome
[Music]
okay yeah
I'm all about that
here
okay they're gonna release Elden ring
and then the next year armored Core six
that's [ __ ] sick here's why I think
Elden ring should win game of the year
and I feel like everyone 95 of people
will agree with me on this when Eldon
ring came out the entire [ __ ] world
was talking about it for months and I
feel like God award just came out and
everyone's already stopped talking about
it Elder ring changed the [ __ ] world
when it came out everyone was talking
about it God of War did for like a week
final fantastic that's my point I do not
own a switch look at that guy go [ __ ]
hard on the flute did he just switch up
instruments
that's his third instrument this guy is
insane come on please please please
please please name of the Year winner is
elderly yes dude yes bro
yes [ __ ] yes
yes
[Applause]
that is actually surprising yes dude
let's go
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
how many awards did they win
game Direction game of the year
[Applause]
art Direction
thank you so much they got rinsed on
musical score they should have won that
100 and last night but at least Mr
George Martin who created the great
Mythos for this game
yes thank you for writing the names of
the characters and then nothing else
thank you George
who's the kid in the back we have faced
so many difficulties while developing
this game so as of the elector I'm
really relieved
and this might not be the you know light
thing to say at the you know the on
occasion of the
um receiving the go deal a set of stray
but I haven't made up my mind to create
even more interesting games than this
one
he wants to make different games he said
that basically everywhere he doesn't
want to make DLC he doesn't want to make
sequels he wants to make new games and I
think that's totally fine as for
elderling we still have
several more things we want to do let's
go um so this getting this never mind
us they're not done making it yet
dude imagine if they didn't win this
they weren't even gonna make DLC I'll
tell you
in firm DLC right there finally
um we would like to you know express our
utmost gratitude to all the fans who
played who enjoyed and supported this
titles thank you for making
um and we create the games we want to
create and do our best because of you
um thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you thank you
hey Martin
you know real quick I want to thank
everybody and say that I think I want to
nominate this award to my reformed
Orthodox Rabbi Bill Clinton thank you
everybody
who the [ __ ] is this kid
hello what just happened did this kid
destroy the game awards
the vet believe me congratulations this
has been such a did this guy
his reform Orthodox I do have one last
special announcement from us what did he
just say hold on I'm sorry that was
really odd you know real quick I want to
thank everybody and say that I think I
want to nominate this award look at
[ __ ] security come out immediately I
don't think that kid was supposed to be
there
does he have anything to do with this
with from software my reformed Orthodox
read by Bill Clinton thank you everybody
all right well
the vet believe me congratulations this
has been such a special night all right
you know what I got to say to that
thanks for playing this awesome game uh
by the way game of the year
just so you know
did you hear Bill Clinton is coming to
Elden right
all right guys
thanks for being here thanks for all the
super chats thanks for hanging out
again appreciate every single one of you
from the bottom of my heart thanks for
watching the video subscribing to the
channel we're almost 200 000. I think we
can get there
probably next year but if we get there
this year I'd be happy with that too
um
expect more videos Man videos are coming
I got three in the works right now